again utter hypocrisy you're talking
about the opening with uh Morgan Freeman
correct
women are treated with so much more
respect I'm from Texas when I go places
here I feel safer 100 I think for what
we Europeans have been doing in the last
3000 years
around the world we should be
apologizing for the next 3000 years
before starting to give moral lessons
with hypocrisy you know another one was
like I heard
[Applause]
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is
show
[Music]
s
I feel like I was here yesterday
I love coming to this community I really
feel at home thank you guys for having
me again me and uh Hassan you know my
father's I used to come here with my
father I didn't even remember his name
is Hassan Oso now I got my brother here
so alhamdulillah we're going to go ahead
and uh
and you guys have seen some of the other
episodes that we filmed and we air it
and alhamdulillah we're making some
history again here filming another
episode of the D show at the Boca Raton
Masjid here in Florida now let's get
into some exciting news you know guys
there's a country
in the world that doesn't allow gum sale
chewing gum do you guys know that it's
been illegal since 1992. they want to
make their country as clean as possible
if you go to that country you know you
can't be chewing gum and putting it you
know under the train seats or on the
seat or whatnot and we got to respect
that but it doesn't seem now like people
you know you're an expert in the area
and you guys know this is a civil rights
attorney someone who is the former
executive of care and you have been on
the front line dealing with many of the
Muslim challenges that are out there the
islamophobia but it seems like it just
creeps his head out now at the World Cup
there's a lot of islamophobia becoming
very visible I think that what's
happening with the World Cup is a great
uh almost like a canary in the coal mine
you know giving off the alert to sift
through and expose the utter hypocrisy
and islamophobia that is deeply
entrenched in a lot of the European
media European government government and
when I say European that includes sort
of the greater Western Europe you know
the U.S and Canada and many of the
western nations are birth product of the
European Heritage and it's becoming
extremely evident to the point where
it's extremely frustrating uh I want
your comments on this there was the
president of the soccer FIFA
Johnny Infantino I believe it is where
he's defending the stance here he's
talking about that he's European and
he's saying that us European we should
be apologizing for what we've done over
the past three thousand years for the
next three thousand years and before we
go ahead and give him moral advice
that's hypocrisy is on the other side
when you pretend to have a moral
and give moral lessons to others
but in reality your situation is maybe
not
that good either
I think for what we Europeans have been
doing in the last 3000 years
around the world who should be
apologizing for the next three thousand
years before starting to give moral
lessons
to people don't criticize Qatar don't
criticize the players don't criticize
anyone criticize FIFA criticize me what
do you think about absolutely I mean
we're seeing a lot of basically Western
white supremacy where they want to
impose their culture their beliefs their
practices upon the world and really
belittle and ridicule those who don't
adopt their ways whatever those ways are
that's unfortunately uh what's happening
and the reality is what you see with the
World Cup being in Qatar I mean
mashallah Qatar is a state that is known
historically for standing by a lot of
beautiful Muslim causes beautiful
philanthropic causes and it's showing
the best of what the Muslim Community
has to offer I mean they've invested
heavily in dawa programs and dawa
campaigns they had an eye of Quran
recited actually in the World Cup
Opening Ceremony so it's very different
to the kind of the Middle East the kind
of Islam and Muslims that the Western
world has promoted so if you look at how
how the Western world has promoted the
Muslim Community over the last several
decades they've showed us as backward
ignorant uh you know dangerous violent
nasty people and there and then you have
the very strong contrast of what's being
presented through the beautiful displays
of the World Cup so I think that's
enraging them so they're finding every
excuse to condemn Qatar to condemn the
Muslim faith to condemn the Muslim
culture and they'll say they're not
doing that but for example as Muslims we
believe our Lord created us from a man
and a woman we believe that men marry
woman woman marry men that is the
natural god-given way for Humanity and
if somebody desires other than that we
don't hate them as an individual but we
certainly believe as God revealed in the
Quran in the injeel The Gospel given to
Jesus peace be upon him and in the Torah
given to Musa to Moses peace upon all of
God's Messengers taught that to deviate
from a permissible relationship that is
only to be found between a husband and
wife to seek sexual fulfillment through
other than that is to destroy one's soul
is to destroy one's body it's is to
destroy one's community so of course the
Muslim faith does not condone endorsing
those Lifestyles that are considered
deviant in all of the faith religions so
the point is they want to impose that
you know you have some of the European
teams wanting to wear flags that support
that kind of lifestyle and so Pilots
like we're not coming into your
countries and imposing our way of life
and saying you have to you have to go to
the mosque and pray we don't go to
Europeans and Americans say you have to
come to the mosque and pray we don't go
to them and say you have to you know
wear a flag that that has the Kalima on
it you know what I'm saying we're not
imposing your way of life why are you
trying to impose your way of life on us
and it isn't just an attack against
Qatar but it's an attack against I would
say Muslim beliefs but really
traditional abrahamic beliefs as a whole
it's an attack against uh you know the
Divine message that Allah sent to All
humanity and it's it's very very
hypocritical I'm sorry one more Point
Eddie I mean you you see
the German team you know last year or or
whenever it was
one of the Muslim players on the German
team spoke out for the oppression and
the Injustice that our uyghur brothers
and sisters were going through
what did the Germans do did they support
him they punished them did they did they
did they endorse him no they punished
him to the point where he was forced off
the team he was punished for speaking
his voice
and his hypocritical teammates now when
they're on Qatar they want to cover
their mouths you know trying to shame
kotov trying to shame the Muslim world
you know for certain for certain reasons
but okay why didn't you cover your
mouths when your own teammate was
punished for speaking about the
slaughter of Muslims that is happening
in China the BBC is another example the
BBC they aired the the opening
ceremonies of the Olympics they had no
problem airing the even though China was
persecuting and slaughtering and
torturing and enslaving our eager Muslim
brothers and sisters but if Muslim blood
is being shed it's okay to turn a blind
eye it's okay to support the state
but that same BBC One cotton had an
opening ceremony with a powerful message
that if you don't didn't watch I urge
you to Google it and watch it that
showed that Allah created us from
different nations and tribes that we can
learn from each other it had a message
of Peace of unity of love they didn't
want to hear it again utter hypocrisy
you're talking about the opening with uh
Morgan Freeman correct BBC did not hear
that they didn't air that but they
didn't have a problem airing uh the
Chinese uh opening ceremony for the
Olympics wow yeah that's amazing they
didn't open it they didn't air it wow
subhanallah you even had Piers Morgan
didn't he also point out some of the
hypocracy yes talking about the abortion
talking about the illegal occupation of
Iraq and Afghanistan I'm going to catch
up
um and also I gotta say I find a lot of
this Sports watching debate uh laced
with rank hypocrisy and I mean for
example eight of the countries in the
last 32 that's a quarter of the
countries in the World Cup finals uh
Outlaw homosexuality so if you're going
to use that as stick to beat Qatar with
you have to then beat the other seven
countries you don't have a World Cup and
if you don't have it in Qatar which is
the first Middle Eastern country to have
it where do you have the World Cup do
you go to Africa where many countries
it's illegal to be homosexual do you go
there so that rules out that continent
uh do you go to America which has rather
Draconian laws about abortion which play
very badly for example in the UK in
other words once you start putting your
moral Halo right where does this where
does it stop and who is morally clean
enough to actually host a world so are
we are we the country that illegally
invaded Iraq are we morally clean enough
to hostel
fraught with hypocrisy and that's the
other point is since when did the
political games
become such a political event now look I
spent my life in politics speaking truth
to power challenging Injustice generally
you know there is a benefit to certain
functions like the World Cup if they're
done right you know which is to bring
Global communities together and as
people gather you can use that for trade
for business for dawa now what what did
was incredible by the way in Banning
alcohol sales you had people saying
we've never seen games like this because
people are less Rowdy less angry less
destructive
without that because you even have you
have many not just Piers Morgan but
other people who are also seeing the
hypocrisy he was one of them that was
pointing this out and he mentioned some
of these things like who are you now to
be the moral police oh right exactly
wants to be the moral policeman 100 and
and this is the ironic thing
respectfully
no Middle Eastern country has done a
fraction of the global Harms
that some of the western Nations have
done and this is a statistical fact you
can't
debate it I mean I'm an American we're
Americans and America happens to be the
only country that's used nuclear weapons
to incinerate hundreds of thousands of
human beings and we justify it literally
we've burned to the death hundreds of
thousands of babies women children
in the nuclear bombing of Japan
in the illegal invasion of Iraq and
Afghanistan
how many millions were killed or injured
or displaced Isis was created as a
result of that illegal invasion
you know it reminds you the act of the
Quran and if they are told do not cause
corruption on the earth they say we are
only peacemakers but rather they are the
corrupt ones so subhanallah this is the
truth Britain I mean they colonized like
a third of the world
you know I was just watching a brief
clip of the great Shaheed and Scholar
may Allah elevated status of Libya who
was a Quran teacher teaching children in
the desert
but as the Italians were persecuting and
oppressing his people he took our up
arms to resist and he fought for freedom
and liberty and justice
until he was illegally captured and hung
and executed may Allah accepted amongst
the show that so the point here is if
you look at Italy you look at the United
Kingdom you look at the United States I
mean literally they've killed so many
civilians across the world and yet
they're still hosting these kinds of
events and tournaments and nobody's
condemning them and you know it's all
good but when a Muslim country does it
okay now they have to find every single
flaw it's utter hypocrisy it's shameful
and it's time I think as Muslims we
stand up and are proud of our faith and
our heritage and you know we take
ownership of our identity as part of
these countries so I'm a proud American
but I'm gonna tell you what my fellow
Americans it's time we stop worshiping a
human being if you call yourself
Christian and you want to follow Jesus
Christ
follow the one who created Jesus and his
mother
don't follow don't worship a human being
follow Jesus follow Jesus Christ by
worshiping the Lord he worshiped Allah
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
it's timely as Muslims stop being shy
about this like I'm embarrassed man I
see a CEO making eight figures you know
whatever it is in a three-piece suit and
he's praying to a little statue or he's
praying to a man even though he knows
that man used to call upon the greater
one
it's time we stop listen we got kids we
raise them men are are to be men women
are to be women men are to marry women
women are to marry men and if you feel
like you want to do other than that
my brothers and sisters we got to teach
them that's not the right way we have to
be good examples if you feel like you
want to sleep around
and have dozens of sexual partners
that's not the right way if you want to
get wasted every weekend and destroy
your brain cells and kill your liver by
joining the party culture and drink
you're destroying yourselves Islam came
to save you from being a slave to your
desires see Islam says do not be a slave
to your desires be a slave to your lord
modern Western culture teaches you to
worship yourself worship your desires
whatever the self says do you say obey
until the self destroys you
and this has been proven psychologically
those who obey their desires who do
whatever they want every single time
they don't find peace or happiness or
growth in every spiritual path it is
those who resist the desires of the self
who acquire discipline who strive for a
greater good for what's right what's
more what's ethical they are the ones
that grow so my simple point my dear
brother is as an American I want to say
I'm proud to be American because it
gives me freedom to practice my faith
I'm going to use that freedom to say
listen I don't want you to stop hating
me I don't want you to stop discriminate
against me I don't want you to stop
attacking me yeah that's all fine and
dandy but I want you to understand I'm
proud to be Muslim my faith is something
beautiful to offer to all Humanity that
we stop worshiping men and women we stop
worshiping gods of wood and stone and
dollar bills we stop worshiping our own
desires and we start turning to the one
who created us because we will meet him
and then we will know what mattered most
well I hope you guys can feel I can feel
it I hope you can feel it out there this
love this passion you know and it's
coming your way that's why we're doing
this uh pointing out some of the
hypocrisy here just to go on you had and
I think you mentioned one of the names
and there's so many examples you have a
cricket
master who was by the name of Moen Ali
who's just banned from the soccer from
cricket for for wearing a wristband
protesting what was happening in
Palestine you also mentioned the one
soccer player who was punished for
standing up and wearing something or
speaking out at a game for the
oppression of Muslims in China you just
had in Palestine just just happened
right now a young boy was shot dead on
his way to school by Israeli forces and
it seems like the West is more
in a rage because someone could enter
the game because with they denied him
because he had a rainbow shirt this is
what's supposed this is what blows our
minds as American Muslims literally we
see Palestinian children
being killed in Cold Blood by bullets
paid for by our tax dollars in Palestine
by the Israelis and utter Silence from
these so-called human rights world
leaders with their nose up and their
arrogance
but
as a Muslim Society if we say hey you
know what we don't think people should
be ident should be identified by their
sexuality that shouldn't be the
Forefront that's what's what's what's
for the bedroom it's for the bedroom
it's not something to be discussed in
public
then oh there's all the outrage in the
world what utter hypocrisy which shows
that for these people I mean really the
Muslim blood is cheaper than even
people's sexual identity it's it's a
shame the West can start lecturing us on
human rights
when they actually start valuing the
blood of all Humanity equally
there's one more a couple more points
one thing that has not hit mainstream
news and you don't see any of the many
people here probably don't even know
about it most people haven't heard about
it but there's a famous
balenciago it's a clothing brand that
just recently had a young baby girl in
dressed in bondage and promoting what
would be you know as far as like none of
the celebrities so this just shows you
all celebrities our control you don't
see no celebrities talking about the
Balenciaga situation right so that just
shows you all of these celebrities out
here don't let them influence you in any
way because they're controlled by the
people who really influence the world
and this is something very sad there's a
lot of Christians who are outraged there
are a lot of people who are speaking out
against this but you don't see any of
the soccer players any closing of the
mount you don't see any protests for
this exploitation of children that's
happening today's this push you know
about this you know what it is yes I saw
the I mean very disturbing right you
have little kids holding teddy bears of
bondages and bondage items scattered
around the room and a Supreme Court case
that makes room for pedophilia yeah
there's right in why this is like setup
system why is that on the table there in
the ad and what kind of subliminal
messages are they sending and how the
heck did that get approved but I'm not
surprised I mean this is you know one of
the popular songs that's out right now
uh uh it talks about liquor bottles and
a new Valencia and these things the
reason I mention this is we have a
community and a culture that promotes
all sorts of indecency
and then is surprised at the result of
that you know promotes all sort of
sexual indecency I'm not even talking
about homosexual I'm talking about
heterosexual but uh you know having
relationships without respect without
responsibilities Islam says before you
enjoy the company of a woman
dedicate yourself to her honor her
respect her commit to her this is how
you honor do not take substances like
alcohol that destroy your judgment you
know respect your body respect the
opposite gender be a person of Honor you
have the Western culture that says do
what you feel like but they're going to
draw arbitrary moral lines and if you
cross one of those arbitrary moral lines
they create this this fabricated outrage
it's hypocritical you have a culture
that that really struggles with even
issues of rape and consent
um and and what is right and what is
wrong and that is why you have so much
unreported rapes in this country you
have just complete breakdown of families
in this country when are we going to
realize that our own desires cannot be
our Lord we have to find guidance from
the divine that's what it all comes down
to not finding our moral compass from
the Divine when we leave it to ourselves
we lead ourselves to ruin when we submit
that's what means you submit you realize
your weakness and God's greatness and
you submit to his way that is when you
find the peace and the guidance and
security and all of the stuff we're
finding is from a total deviance from
having that pure divinely oriented moral
compass I want to wrap up but it's
really amazing to see Americans who are
living
in this area of the world who are
actually they're not Muslim but they're
stepping up there was a woman who was
complaining about being in an
all-woman's line and then a woman steps
up say Hey you know I want to be in that
line This Girl is shocked about the
ladies only line she doesn't think it
makes her feel very special
it's a security line that's only for
women that they're separated by men and
women not because women are mistreated
because they are better treated as an
American female living in the Middle
East myself I prefer these lines when I
go places I am moved either if there's
not a women's only line I'm typically
moved to the front of the line
especially if I have my children there's
also parking that's just for women and
it's usually the closest to the door and
as well the Metro lines there's a
women's only cart everything over here
on this side of the world in the Middle
East I'm in Dubai women are treated with
so much more respect I'm from Texas when
I go places here I feel safer 100 and
live in that country which is welcoming
and accepting and living with a lot of
different nationalities all living
together it's a very safe environment
I've never felt so safe but it's not as
bad as what people say we've had a great
time here
and we've had a life that we wouldn't
have had in England and then other
people who are coming up and talking
about you know another one is like I
heard the Adan
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you know this reporter and he's like you
know wow it's like you know so amazing
so my point is when people are going to
that because there's been this push like
if you go over there they're gonna chop
your head off all this outlandish crazy
stuff but people who actually get out of
the box out of their neighborhood and
they go and they fly they connect with
Muslims have you yourself seen you know
a chain like we're seeing we're seeing
this hello we're seeing it a lot and you
know even here in the U.S I mean why is
it that so many women who a few years
ago may have been going at the clubs and
drinking whatever they want and sleeping
around and in the bikinis why are they
choosing every day to leave that
lifestyle to say there is no God but
Allah alone having their sins purified
dressing in hijab and modesty praying
five times a day giving up those kinds
of Lifestyles why are they giving up
that so-called freedom embracing Islam
by the thousands regularly it's their
choice because they realize a hedonistic
way of worshiping your desires will
never give that peace we'll never give
that success and certainly will not
benefit us when we breathe or last they
people are thirsty to know their lord to
know where they came from to know where
they're going to know the one who
created them and who provides for them
and who loves them and the rules of
Islam it isn't about punishment it isn't
about harshness it's it's just simply
your instruction manual you buy a car it
comes with a manual what to do what not
to do so you don't wreck it same way
Allah created us to give us a manual for
how we can have that peace that
Tranquility that success and that
happiness and there's a reason people
are choosing to leave the Deviant
Lifestyles and I'm raising some whether
they're men or women by choice because
they realize a life of drinking of
alcohol of drugs of of
open relationships it doesn't bring that
peace of mind that the honor and the
guidance and the modesty and dignity
that Islam brings to humanity gives them
and that's why they're choosing and
that's why we're grateful to be Muslim
and that's why we invite everybody
watching to say you know get to know
more about Islam if you're Muslim
appreciate it don't take it for granted
invest in learning your faith and if
you're not Muslim yet we're waiting for
you remember we all have one Creator and
he sent Abraham Moses Jesus and Muhammad
as the best Role Models peace be upon
them all to guide us to him let us learn
their way and follow their footsteps
that we can be sources of mercy and
guidance for Humanity and that's
ultimately what Islam will make you
Islam does make you hateful you're not
going to look at any one person who's
engaging in any form of sin and hate
them rather you're going to feel a
sympathy that you want them to find that
peace that they're looking for at the
bottom of a liquor bottle but that you
know they will never find it you want
them to be the best version of
themselves that is what Islam makes it
brings out the best in people and that's
what we want to do together to build the
best Society for Humanity thank you my
brother thank you for being with us
again here on the D show thank God
Almighty locks him to bless you I mean
it's always a pleasure brother Eddie
love you may Allah accept your efforts
and I hope everybody supports the great
work you're doing does that come on
thank you guys for tuning in and if
you'd like to learn more go ahead and
pick up it's a gift from us to you a
free copy of the Quran go to the D show
com will get one mailed out to you and
make sure you tune in here every week to
the D show until next time peace be with
you from Boca Raton Florida
to my brothers and sisters I'm here
today to appeal to you to support the
dean Center at Dallas Center first of
its kind in the United States perhaps in
the globe to support dawa to non-muslims
who are interested in Islam my dear
brother Eddie from the dean show is
championing this cause the building is
secured there's a contract on it it's 35
000 square feet it has plenty of room to
run excellent programs and we just need
your help and support no matter how
little in making this Center become a
reality and you will have a reward from
Allah for it until the day of judgment
[Music]
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedine
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum